three-time NBA champion who is now deep
into the league of legends the most
played PC game in the world over a
hundred million active players and the
League of Legends eSports 14
professional leagues worldwide man who's
wearing the echo fox gear right now Rick
Fox yeah like a millennial right you
like part doctor bus part like you know
know if I could get a percentage of what
doctor bus has been to the professional
ownership world of sports I would be how
did you get involved with all this well
I I just a passion and a love for video
games to begin with I mean I cut my
teeth as a competitor playing video
games before I even found the basketball
so that started there played video games
throughout my life introduced him to my
son it's how we spent time together and
then he introduced me to a whole world
that had it started to evolve around the
video game industry where developers
like riot and League of Legends had
created leagues where players were
actually making a living being a
professional players right and so I went
to a live event in Madison Square Garden
about three years ago and took it in you
know an arena that I'd played many times
before and got the chills and saw the
crowd sold-out crowd and fell in love
with it so you know so many people who
haven't been to one of these events or
don't know about it don't take it
seriously
right okay because there's video gaming
right but I mean video games when video
games are released it makes more money
than movies make an entire year maybe
even all of movies together yeah so it's
a serious big business to say the least
so how would you get involved as an
owner was it somebody who invited you in
or you said I want in it right well the
barrier of entry a few years back was a
little easier than it is today
I mean franchises today sell for twenty
thirty million dollars I had an
opportunity through like I said just an
experience that I had at Madison Square
Garden that led me to go on the journey
to find out what it what it would take
to become a league of Legends owner and
it was at that time that I bought a slot
like basically buying a expansion team
that wasn't doing so well and
I came in took over that slot and became
an owner very quickly I realized I had
to get a coach and get a facility and
get players and negotiate contracts and
you like that yeah it was invigorating
it was overwhelming it gave me a true
sense of what it meant to be an owner in
sports it's one thing to be on the field
of play it's another thing to be to be
the behind scenes helping execute that
great you know graciously and gratefully
I had a lot of partnerships and and help
in that area so you know I'd never run
an organization before so I learned
quick on the job but I had a lot of help
doing it okay is it difficult handling
Talent yes it can be especially when you
come from up the road here with the
Lakers where you know the expectations
are championship levels so you you leave
that arena and you expect to win
championships in a new arena yeah and
it's not that easy you know when you
talk about the understanding of what
this world is and the importance of how
serious it is it is it is not only my
life as an owner yeah but it's a group
of players who I now I'm a steward of
their professional career per se
I had a shepherd dem through not only
becoming pros and learning how to be a
pro because it is in a lot of ways a new
industry right I have to Shepherd them
into learning how to become champions
and that that requires them
understanding yes they have talent yes
they have the skill and and they're
putting in the repetition to develop the
the mastery of it but you know there's
the on-field and there's the off feel
right there's the in-game and out of
game if you don't understand how to
handle your money and understand how to
handle the critics and how to be a good
teammate and how to be coachable all
those things that go with any
traditional sports then you're gonna
probably be out of a job Rick Fox here
in the Rich Eisen show no names here
though I mean cuz you know having been a
player for as long as you were in the
Association there's always those
teammates or players where an owner or
on a ship would just roll their eyes and
you got to be kidding me I got a deal
with this yeah what's the craziest story
of you having to deal with a gamer
well no names no names but you know it
when you are coming up in the gaming
industry depending on your choice of
game a lot of times you hone those
skills in a solo atmosphere all right
well you home them is
you were out in the gym shooting the
shots getting shots up but then you're a
part of a team environment so you have
to learn how to interact with other
people you're not on your couch in the
basement
yeah or anywhere right I mean today's
with with technology today you can play
games on your phone you should play them
on your laptop against anybody anyone
who's anywhere in the world and I think
that's what has created the
accessibility to technology has created
the growth and at such a rapid pace
right at a young man that went from
player and became a coach and he'd never
been a coach before so in all fairness
to him he you know I've had some great
coaches Dean Smith you know Phil Jackson
I've had some of the legends of the game
so my expectation level for this young
man to evolve into a great coach was you
know the standards were high at first
but very quickly learned that you know
if he was gonna be the coach I needed
him to be yes I was gonna have to impart
some of this coaching wisdom that I've
had in my life once this young man well
sure enough I think I tried to get him
there a little too fast and it was a
little overwhelming for him and quite
frankly I remember coming in one day and
I was looking for him to be in there
early like most coaches would get in at
6:00 and watch film and be ready to go
and get the guys going and I said
where's the coach at and he says oh he's
he's not here right now I go Wars yet
and they went to social media and they
pulled it up and he was checking in on
the ride and Harry Potter universe he's
got a job he's a coach now what does he
do with it Universal and my friend
looked at me and he said have you not
seen the big big billboards like you
can't blame and I said well okay I gotta
talk to him about this but he may agree
made great strides the rest of the year
and it's just you know it's getting the
understanding of the seriousness of this
right I mean there's the average player
in this in this league makes three
hundred and thirty three thousand
dollars a year with multiple year
contracts so you're making a living and
you saw those responsibilities that have
come with that coaches don't fall too
far behind that yeah and these are young
men and women who make up this industry
who are learning about you know the
traditional sport model but a sports
model is a model
it's owned and if you don't make it to
the top I mean that they say there's a
hundred million players right yeah
there's about a thousand pros globally
and so that's the small percentage but
if you don't make that just like NBA or
MLB an NFL you can be a coach a GM an
agent a journalist you know you can
cover it all and be a part of the world
unless you go he went four corners on
you Rick Fox here owner of echo Fox in
the league of legends joining us here on
the Rich Eisen show
okay so LeBron coming here is a no
brainer right I mean like he's built for
this town at this very moment for this
Lakers franchise post Kobe needing to
get Fannie's back in the seat Magic
Johnson shopping for the groceries with
Rob polenka right perfect
this is it used to say it's on paper
right it's all there but now it's not on
paper it's actually in that building up
the street he is actually here I've seen
it on social media there's proof right
I'm happy the town's been waiting for
him I mean any town would have been
waiting for him to show up but we've I
think we're there with the town that's
right for him not only for him to bring
his talents and drag a young team and
and young and maybe players that are
still trying to find a consistent home
to a level that I think can can be
warranted of what Laker fans are used to
seeing and it's gonna take his
leadership it's gonna take his
commitment but we know that already
about him and I think what's best for
him now is that after the game is done
for him he's in the right City based on
the things he wants to do that means
great things he's doing already he's
doing it already I mean you know it just
it seems like every two days there's a
project being Spring Hill entertainment
with him and maverick Carter and what
they're doing so so there's that I mean
how do you think all the youngins on
this roster are gonna fare with him I
mean because it once it eventually games
are gonna have to be played here yes
and we're gonna have to see this all
play out rajon rondo and having a Lonzo
ball yeah competition it seems the
competition is good it's healthy
especially when you're young it pushes
you I think sometimes you can get a
get a crop of young really talented
players that can find themselves in an
organization of franchise yes the
pressure alone here in LA is great but
they can find themselves maybe with an
expectation of minutes and expectation
because they look around and they see
that they're the future but you know
they I think some of them have grown and
but LeBron is gonna provide them an
opportunity just like Kobe did on his
way out I think to give them a snapshot
of the work ethic he will raise their
level of play but he will demand of them
that they they suit up and show up and
work at it at a level or I'd like to
think you know at a certain point you
get opportunity but then opportunity
will pass you by if you don't make the
most of it so what do you think Lonzo
ball is the real deal do you think um
well I've seen a year and I I like all
that is that is there in the talent
Department oh oh it's hard to it's hard
to heat praise I come from the era where
you don't really he preys on rookies you
know you don't really project out but
this is a different generation there's a
lot of you know expectation and
projection of the greatness before it
actually arrives and maybe sometimes
that helps with confidence but in in the
area of our young players I'd like to
see them earn that and I like to see
them improve and that's what the summers
for so I know he had he had some surgery
and I know do I doubt that he he's
putting in the work no because I think
when you see LeBron James as a team man
you see some of the other veterans that
are coming in you understand that that
you're gonna have to earn your minutes
regardless of last season well here's
the issue to Rick but Rick Fox here in
the Rich Eisen show there's there's that
team up north that just seems to be
unbeatable absolutely unbeatable how
would you deal with that if you were in
the NBA right now where you know that
there's another team that maybe you're
not on right that everybody thinks is
unbeatable and has proven to be as such
how do you deal with something well you
tap into the fact that every season is a
new season which brings a lot of moving
pieces they do they do right now again
defending champions look as strong as
can be on the add boogie cousins but
they are now going to be heading into I
think a fifth year if they make it to
June
to the finals I know what how taxing
that is I know how difficult that is now
the rosters deep so it does you know
it'll give Steve Kerr the flexibility of
you know really parsing out those
minutes responsibly throughout the
season the skill and the talent levels
they're off the charts so yes they pose
a difficult Road you know to get by them
but it's not insurmountable it really
isn't you know some team and we saw what
Huston was doing last year some team
will rise to a level when they represent
a challenge now are the Lakers a team
not right now not today but 82 games is
a long way and I wouldn't bet against
LeBron James putting them in a position
and the reason I say that is I mean when
I saw what he did last year as a leader
to that Cavalier team that literally
blew up their roster in the middle of
the season I thought there was no way
they would make it to the finals and I
know I was the Eastern Conference and he
debate the conference's are weaker than
than the Western Conference but he still
was able to like a chess master figure
out the pieces he had to work with and
get those guys working for each other
and and unfortunately you know he didn't
have enough there with him and they fell
short but even in falling short I still
saw signs of him continually to figure
out he was his great he's great he's
he's ever been yeah yeah and that's
really making that make that is amazing
I mean I've seen the great so I played
on that play I was Larry Bird's rookie
and Kevin McHale's rookie and I mean I
suppose how old I am but how does it how
does that come I was amazing I mean I I
mean it was Larry what Larry's last year
I mean he had his back and I watched him
fight through you know his back
challenges to get to the court every
night the preparation was there and and
you know so I watched and I got a look
at what it meant to be a pro in the game
and you know and I spent some time with
Mike him from college days at Carolina
and so I saw the greats work Kobe and
Shaq I saw the greats
you know mature and grow into their
excellence so it's there they're gonna
get to see it in LeBron LeBron is one of
those guys you know they can he can drag
you can drag a group of men who were
willing to actually follow you can drag
him to really you know championship
level and I am man today to ask you this
question to wrap up our association chat
Rick
is the sports talk radio hot-button
subject of Michael were LeBron who yeah
right i mean i i i don't know how you
did i either first of all it would have
been a blessing to see them in the same
error but it's also a blessing that they
we've had what 40 years israel amazing
bass calling in between we Kobe in
between you know and and and Shaq yeah
two great players sir it's hard for me
not to not to acknowledge what I've
witnessed LeBron do the last few years
when it talks when you talk about the
consistency of World Championship
appearances he's won what three I think
it is and maybe you know that the the
lost column might stack up in the debate
against him at some point but I think
he's gonna probably play for another
five six years I I hope in a Laker
uniform and I think he will start to
knock down some of the all-time great
records individually in the game that
with coupled with having won
championships and MVPs I don't I don't
know how you deny him as the greatest
ever at that point and I think he's
making a great case off the court to to
be you know that ambassador going
forward throughout the rest of his life
and with the team echo fox yeah as the
owner we've already talked about the
interesting personalities as the gamers
if not the coaches
is there a Lavar ball in I was darn near
close as an owner for a minute I had to
slow down yes I mean there's the the
same parents and and and and support
staff of girlfriends and wives are not
so much wives quite yet but girlfriends
exist in our game they are as supportive
and is passionate about their their
their players and they give their two
cents oh yeah oh yeah they chime in you
know social media is huge in society as
it is but if you go to lol eSports calm
and you want to find out more about
eSports you go you'll find that that the
World Championship started on October
first and this is all South South Korea
and so we're excited about that and and
it'll be it'll be
so you'd rather talk about that than
Lemar ball do the gamers do the gamers
parents take their children a little way
need to get better they go to Korea and
they travel the eSports is global it is
no joke there is this league itself has
over 100 professional teams globally and
so you know 16 of them will get to
compete for the championship over the
next 21 days starting October 1st and
and they'll be they'll be 80 80 million
people watching that championship I'm
believe last me last year in China they
filled the Olympic Stadium a hundred
thousand people watch unreal so when you
think about that right and it is it is
not it it's not to to compete with
traditional sports it's it's has it I
think it just has a seated entertainment
and in sports in general and competition
it's just it's a part of the ecosystem
yeah and who is the best gamer when you
were playing I imagine what was it at
NBA we played a lot of Madden ok a lot
of Madden photo release or so so yeah it
was the best at um you know where you
Derek and Brian shot myself and Ron we
all we all kind of played I don't know
if we ever made it through rf2 who was
the best okay but guys play a lot more
today I mean I think he's our partners
of our organization and I went out to
training camp and Erin judge and Greg
Bird and these guys play play games and
they grew up on it so they don't know
they didn't come out from our era right
which is put down the control and get
out of the house right and you know you
didn't know as a parent where that with
gameplay lat right but Reds if I told
you today League of Legends has over 800
kids on scholarship and universities
getting an education and some of those
players are now playing professionally
in our league two of them going to the
World Championships this month then you
realize there's a path to pro and then
you think to yourself okay well my son
wanted to be a pro he's not a pro but we
know what he's doing his game designing
so he's a part of the industry in a way
that still allows him to be passionate
about what he loves
well Congrats on being an owner the gear
that you earned is pretty sweet today
people get this here I I gotta say
you're some okay
the I love the logo it's pretty sweet
yes it's like it's Fox in flames and all
that sort of stuff it looks like
box it looks sweet man thanks grats on
that and congrats on your success in
your newest act with it with the League
of Legends with echo fox and comeback
think I will come back and look at an
amazing set I appreciate that
Golf button and any time work on your
puting game here anytime you want by the
way it was I think I saw the other day
on Twitter
it was the 41st anniversary of the atari
joystick coming out love it because
that's what I'm talking that's that's
that's what time is all that is that
your first guess or error yeah that's
her pong pong my brother and I we had to
tell a star pong where we would you know
play each other and it was nasty yeah it
was really not so you're saying now I
can get a scholarship on pong is there a
pong fantastic Rick Fox is here the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience